you did a play with one of my favorite
actors of all time as Al Pacino you did
a play with the legendary Al Pacino
what's that like
I mean it's Al Pacino it was I looked up
to him myself growing up and the
opportunity to do a project with him I
was like sign me up I'll spend 15 weeks
and a 990 seat theater right for no
money right pass on all this other stuff
it was it was great but there was one on
opening night I kicked him and it wasn't
intentional there's a scene where we
blocked it I was a big stunt and I'm
supposed to just sort of sweep the leg
right and I and the adrenaline was going
opening-night the timing was off and I
kicked the crap out of Al Pacino's leg
accidentally accidentally and I see his
eyes like those Scarface eyes those
those Michael Corleone eyes and I think
that they're like big and I just saw him
I tagged him good and then I actually I
had to exit I had to get off stage and
he had another 12 pages to do with Jesse
Eisenberg and I'm backstage just
panicking like what is gonna what
version of how am I gonna get right and
so he comes back there and I'm sweating
look I feel like Pope is coming out
right right yeah sure Al I'm so sorry
I'm so sure you kicked me in the shin do
not do that again or I will replace you
aski all rich replace you with skeet all
right that's the big threat what if
that's his threat for everything in life
please I don't like this bagel you'll
get a bagel I'm replacing you Eschete
over it poor bagel guy Adam what are you
talking about so he but he's it just
gotta be just an incredibly rewarding
experience though actus absolutely yeah
I mean it was I it but this is even even
better experience for me being with you
here
this is a highway thank you thank you
you're a terrific actor yeah that's all
I have to say yep sure is better than
hanging out with Al Pacino
you